Uuuuuuuhh we back!!! Diavolo here, and you dirty,
filthy anime only’s better click off this video
if you dont wanna get spoiled on the PINACLE of
battles that happen inside of Shibuya! This fight
stars 3 of the series most beloved characters who
over the space of 5 grueling chapters lay their
body, soul and future all on the line for the
sake of their own personal gain! Apart from Todo,
mans here to back his brother up and double team
this patchy creep. So sit back, subscribe if you
are new around here and interested in a multitude
of similar styled anime and manga content,
but now get ready for 100% the greatest
portion of the Shibuya Incident Arc
Following one of the saddest moments so far in
the series, and as Nobara seemingly lay there,
still right in front of his eyes, Yuji's
resolve shatters. Taking the opportuning
to possibly take out another stupid student,
Mahito follows up breaking Yuji's spirit by
battering the sorcerer's body into the ground
and ceiling with his own application of black
flash. He kicks him in the head and proclaims
that Yuji came to Shibuya with some pathetic
half assed determination. That naivety
now is what's left him open. THIS IS WAR,
not some battle of emotions to fix sublime issues,
but a clash of truths against his fragile justice.
He’s figured it out now, Yuji and him
are one in the same, but he will kill
without a second thought. Just like how Yuji
saves people without any hesitation. This is
now the insticts of a curse, against the so
called pride obtained by a baseline human.
Its a battle to determine who will be the
ones standing in 100 years from now...
Asking the sorcerer, how the hell he ever thought
he’d be able to beat him or if he has any idea
about the amount of curses he’s stepped on and
killed. Mahito hears no response, making him
confident that Yuji’s done for. He jokingly states
that, he actually cares about how many people he’s
taken out. However as he morphs his hand into
a praying mantis appendage, screams that surely
he’ll eventually forget about Yuji too before
going to slash down on the knocked out sorcerer.
Taking him by surprise, and just before
the cursed spirit lands the killing blow,
the sound of a single clap echoes
through the subway corridor.
Suddenly, Mahito is left discombobulated and
confused standing in an entirely different
spot in the hallway, wondering who the
hell this guy with a scar on his face is.
Having taken the cursed spirit's place, one
of Kyoto's most handsome men stands over Yuji.
Peacefully, he recites a poem that conveys the
idea that those who prosper are also destined
to decline. In this world of jujutsu though,
there are some who are considered the exception,
and while taking off his jacket and
saying hello to his best friend,
Todo proudly re-iterates, that
they... They are the exception.
Entering the platform himself,
Kyoto first-year Arata rushes
upto Todo's side and informs him that
he's finished treating Nobara with his
cursed technique. Arata who takes more of aa
managerial role has the ability Pain Killer:
This technique allows Arata to stop existing
injuries from getting any worse... More on that
in a second. Arata doesn't think she’ll
survive and asks his senpai not to place
any blame on him if she doesn't make it
through. Uninterested in idle chatter,
Todo simply asks Arata to treat his brother
aswell. Snapping his head in Yuji’s direction,
Todo yells at his broken partner that its time
to wake up as this fight has only just begun.
Curled up and in the fetal position, Yuji
can't bring himself to get up and fight
any longer. He reveals that Nanami died as
well as Nobara. Coupled with his guilt over
allowing Sukuna to rampage through the city,
the young man is physically unable to forgive
himself. Screaming out loud that “he couldn't
do anything and that he’s nothing more than
a murderer” the student falters and begins to
believe people will die simply because he lives.
Love struck by Yuji's beaten demeanor, Mahito
leaps at the trio of sorcerers and attempts to
slash them with a serrated arm blade. Todo
activates Boogie Woogie to switch Arata's
position on the ground behind him with Mahito's
position in the air. He then without hesitation
claps again to swap Mahito with Yuji, positioning
the cursed spirit's back right infront of him.
Unable to block, Todo delivers a powerful snap
kick that sends his adversary crashing into
the ground. The impact ricochets Mahito toward
Arata, but Todo slaps his big hands together and
trades places so his peer doesn't suffer any
damage. Across of the other side of the room,
Mahito quickly recovers and laughs from the thrill
of grappling with this new opponents ability.
Stoically, Todo re-iterates to his brother
that now, he is amongst MEN! He needn’t
limit himself with such narrow mind-ness,
they, they are Jujutsu Sorcerers. Him,
Todo, Nobara and Nanami. They together are
Jujutsu Sorcerers, so even if one is defeated,
as long as they continue to live,
no one will have truly passed.
There are no sins or punishments. Instead the
moment they choose the life of a sorcerer,
they cannot be limited by the death of a
friend. One cant look for meaning or logic
in death and those who do, can at time’s
defile the memories of those who passed.
Throwing his jacket to the ground,
ready to place his life on the line.
He asks Yuji what he's been entrusted
with.... He doesn't need to answer now,
however until he finds that answer, Todo
pleads with him to never stop moving. For
those who live the life of a Jujutsu Sorcerer,
this is the punishment that they must endure.
Done with getting Yuji back on track, Todo
charges ahead to face the special grade
cursed spirit while Arata applies his technique
to Yuji's wounds. Arata explains his technique,
Pain Killer. As I said Arata can pretty much
sustain the damage already occurred so it wont
get worse. He also reveals that he's done the
same for Nobara and reassures Yuji there is a
very small possibility she could survive.
Its not a zero perfect chance of survival,
but as he goes to leave with the broken girl,
exclaims that he mustn't get his hopes up. BUT
YA KNOW WHAT DOES THE ENTIRE FREAKING COMMUNITY
DECIDE TO DO FOR YEARS AT THIS POINT. Get their
damn hopes up, like oml at this point cant
we just confirm its most likely girls not
around anymore. Either way tangent over,
like all of us muppets reading the series,
Yuji also has his spirit slightly
reignited thanks to Aratta's kindness.
Infront of Todo, Mahito transforms his torso
into a spiked net, and lunges his top half at
the sorcerer with the intention of ensnaring
him. Todo claps to change their positions and
reinforces his hand with cursed energy to grab
the netted park of Mahito's body from behind.
Annoyingly, Todo is just to damn strong
and he straight up tore the netting apart,
allowing the sly dog Mahito to transfigure
the back of his body to mirror the front.
Above the hulked up beauty that is
Todo, Mahito nearly grabs down on him,
but the sorcerer claps again to get right back
behind his adversary, making Mahito stumble forth.
Looking down on him, Todo taunts Mahito, asking
if the curse even wants to touch him. Thinking
to himself, Mahito is impressed with the
sorcerer's ability to dodge while keeping
his distance from Yuji, but... he still
has a few more tricks in store himself.
Randomly and from behind, a small transfigured
human that Mahito must've dropped earlier,
activates and transforms into a large
spike, almost skewering the sorcerer.
Although his shirt is slightly cut, Todo
avoids the spike by simply adjusting his
posture. Preparing his next strike,
Mahito hopes that Todo will switch,
as right now he’s sure he’ll eventually figure
it out! He can feel it swelling up inside of him,
and as time slows, thinks that he wants
it again, he’s so close... He can almost
taste the true essence of his soul, ready
to bust forth with another black flash..
Suddenly, a single clap rings out, gifting Mahito
that moment he wanted. Yet to his left now stands
our boy, having taken the place of his brother
and with his fists fully embued in cursed energy.
Remembering the final words Nanami said.
Yuji apologizes for almost taking the easy
road out and using his sins as an
excuse to run away from everything.
With his fist throbbing with cursed energy,
Yuji unleashes his point black Black Flash,
connecting with Mahito and shattering the cursed
spirits guard, sending him rocketing back across
the Platform inside of shibuya station.
With his resolve returned, Yuji remembers
his teacher and tells him that he’ll be sure
to take on his share of suffering aswell.
Amused, Mahito smiles and regenerates his
arm, commenting that Yuji, that little rascal,
is back from the dead. Finally if you ask
me, Shheeeesh, Todo tears his shirt off,
ever continuing to undress himself
and welcomes Yuji back to the fight.
Man I love this battle, just as soon
as Yuji’s down in the dumps again,
who shows up and manages to get his ass back
on track, well no one other than his big bro,
Todo. Out of all of his teachers, Nanami,
Gojo, Choso I guess at points and Todo. I
find it funny how Yuji always progresses
to an even higher degree in some aspect
with Todo by his side. Todo is Talk-No-Jutsu.
Also why im off tangent, Check out some new
merch i've been making recently. Trying to
make it more anime based and include things
from a variety of series. So if you have
any moments you’d like to see on a shirt,
from a bunch of different series i've covered,
let me know below and ill see what I can cook up!
Back in the fight, Mahito shapeshifts his fingers
into a long double-edged blade and tries to stab
Yuji with it. Countering, Yuji parries the hand
and grabs the spike by catching it between his
fingers. Throwing a fat kick towards Mahito
from behind, Yuji attempts to throw the curse
into his partner. Mahito attempts to counter by
transforming his free arm into a spiked vine and
lashing it at Todo. The grade 1 sorcerer claps
to switch his position with the curse and lands
behind Yuji, avoiding the attack. Doing that
same weird thing as last time, Mahito swaps
his body’s polarity around to avoid taking the
hit from behind. He then quickly enlarges both
his arms and uses his forearms to block Todo
and Yuji from capitalizing on the situation.
Taking a moment to think, Mahito recognizes that
Todo is at full health and doubts one touch from
Idle Transfiguration would be enough to
kill him. When it comes to Yuji though,
he believes the student is nearing his
end at only around 10% left. Himself,
after all of the attacks he’s taken, think’s
he’s probably around 40%. Surprisingly, Mahito
admits that, even though Nobara is a nobody,
she managed to leave her mark on the fight.
Sucking his hands back to their original size,
Mahito notes that first he needs to deal with
this switching. He transforms his left arm into
a fin-like slicing weapon to fend off Todo and
tosses a transfigured human out of his right
hand at Yuji. Todo immediately switches his
place with the transfigured human to get behind
the curse, taking Mahito completely off guard,
who slices his own ability in half.
Looking like a stunned mullet,
Mahito was unaware Todo was even able to
switch places with a non-living subject
and is impressed with how he picked up on his
transfigured humans energy before he released it.
Feeling himself now, Todo believes his friendship
with Yuji can't last if he remains stagnant. Even
Mahito this dirty rat of a cursed spirit can use
Black Flash...He ponders, if its him thats being
left behind now? Asking himself if he’s gonna
allow his brother to feel alone once more,
Aoi Todo transcends who he once was, to step up
and kick Mahito with perfect timing, unleashing
his first ever use of Black Flash. Again and just
like with Yuji, the blow is powerful enough that
it shatters Mahito’s blocking arm and sends
him sliding back across the station. Although
unlike Yuji, this has no effect on Mahito's soul,
due to him not possesing that ability. However,
now that all three of these individuals
have released a black flash, the cursed
spirit recognizes that all three fighters
are reaching 120% of their maximum potential.
Randomly something starts swelling up inside of
Mahito’s mouth. Instantly after, the curse vomits
numerous small transfigured humans into his hands
and crushes them all together in his palms to
activate Soul Multiplicity. With no warning, the
jacked up Mahito immediately unleashes Body Repel,
creating several giant monstrous mouths
to attack the two stunned sorcerers. The
technique is so demonstrably strong that it
easily breaks through the ceiling of the subway,
spewing itself into the streets of Shibuya
above ground. Being the brute genius he is,
Todo recognizes that Mahito is countering
Boogie Woogie by attacking from every direction.
Atop the mass of transfigured humans,
Mahito screams out to Yuji that, this is it,
its their last chance to curse each-other!
Mad cause this freak somehow forgot about HIM,
Todo claps, placing Mahito right next to him.
Unconcerned for his own safety, he straight up
tackles the curse to the floor, allowing a
pissed Yuji to straight up kick a man while
he’s down. Un-nerved, Mahito quickly detaches
his own head before Yuji could kick it off.
Mahito's dismembered body spawns its own freaking
bug like head, while simultaneously spinning its
blade arms rapidly, nearly cutting the two
sorcerers. While Todo jumps above one blade,
Yuji ducks below the other, giving Mahito's
detached head time to forms its own separate body.
Slamming a few souls together, Mahito activates
Soul Multiplicity. A technique in which all of the
souls with weak rejection come together to form
one body known as the Polymorphic Soul Isomer.
This is why this battle is so freaking top tier,
Mahito’s JoJo esc stance behind his stand ass
looking soul isomer, but more or less what im
trying to say is the dudes constant ability to
evolve overtime is crazy. Every day he’s just
tinkering with his ability trying to craft the
most devious and soul violating weapons. He is
a demon and how he taunts Yuji is phenomenal.
Flashing back into the heat of battle, Todo claps
repeatedly and continues to switch positions
between the five fighters on the platform. He
believes that Mahito's original dismembered
body contains 80% of his power while the head
possesses 20%. The plan is for Yuji to finish
off the detached head while Todo takes care
of the transfigured human, which he guesses
is probably around a grade 2 or 3. However,
Todo grossly underestimates the Polymorphic
Soul Isomer's power and is caught off guard by
a powerful backfist. Reeling from a hit so hard,
it had to have been Yuki, Todo can do nothing
as the Polymorphic Soul Isomer follows up with
a right hook that sends the grade 1 sorcerer
crashing through the side of a building.
Continuing the uncontrollable path, Todo
falls out of the other side of the building,
stunned from the impact. The Polymorphic Soul
Isomer jumps above the injured sorcerer and
attempts to crush him on the way down, luckily,
Todo lands on his feet and is able to avoid the
follow up kick from his opponent. Picking up
a piece of the flying rubble, Todo imbues it
with cursed energy before tossing it at the
Soul Isomer. The rock goes right past the top
of the transfigured human's head. Instantly, Todo
switches with the rock to get behind his opponent
and delivers a powerful right hook that literally
turns the Polymorphic Soul Isomer into a pancake.
To Todo's surprise, the transfigured human only
took one hit because the Polymorphic Soul Isomer's
explosive power comes from expending so many
weak souls at once. Todo figures out how the
transfigured human attack specialists work
just as two more arrive to confront him.
Feeling free of Todo's interference, Mahito piles
on the pressure again Yuji. Slamming his hands
down, he activates Body Repel, creating long
eel-like transfigured heads with spikes along
the side to attack. Yuji gets between each of the
attacks in order to find an opening to drop-kick
Mahito. The curse counters by grabbing Yuji's
leg and throwing him into the ground below.
The impact breaks apart the ground and sends
Yuji's body along the street, back to the area
of Sukuna’s destruction. While Yuji is reeling,
Mahito moves in to capitalize. However, the
cursed spirit is disappointed to find that Todo
has suddenly rejoined Yuji's side. Standing there,
Big bro Todo taunts Mahito for really trying to
avoid a two-on one fight. This a beating boy.
Blown away with how not even two Polymorphic Soul
Isomer's were enough to stall Todo. He knows that
landing a hit on him will be difficult and using
Domain Expansion with Yuji around will invoke
Sukuna's rage. At this current point, Mahito can't
configure his barrier to exclude specific people,
so there is only one thing he can resort
to. On a whim, Mahito decides to employ
a technique he saw a specific demon use. The
special grade decides that it's all-or-nothing
and activates his domain expansion, the self
embodiment of perfection, for 0.2 seconds!
Instantly, Todo responded by casting a Simple
Domain he learned from Yuki. Even faster and
unconcerned for himself, Yuji boosts it towards
Mahito in an attempt to exorcise him before he
could activate idle Transfiguration. Sadly for
the two brothers though, the Fastest was Mahito,
who had already awakened through Black Flash.
Usually when casting a domain, a sorcerer needs
to realize an innate domain, then activate the
instant effect of a cursed technique. Thanks to
his awakening due to black flash, Mahito was able
to pull off this unrealistically fast combination.
All of a sudden, Mahito enters Sukuna's
innate domain and tells him shut up and watch,
as Yuji will be dead before they
can even switch. Back in Shibuya,
Mahito’s Self-Embodiment of Perfection disappears
just as quickly as it was cast. Looking down,
Todo watches as his left arm transfigures,
concerning Yuji who stops dead in his tracks.
Running up, Mahito punches Yuji from
behind and knocks him to the ground.
Thinking on the spot, Todo acts quickly and
severs his own hand using cursed energy. However,
this leaves Todo defenseless against
Mahito's next attack. Unable to
activate Idle Transfiguration so soon after
casting his domain, Mahito instead opts for
a physical attack and lands a devastating
direct hit to Todo’s gut with black flash!
The power obtained in Mahito's Black Flash sends
Todo shooting back across the destroyed area of
Shibuya. Despite suffering a direct hit, Todo
survives and is able to land on his feet. Blown
away with how in the world he survived, Mahito
notices that the sorcerer concentrated all his
cursed energy to the area of impact in order to
minimize the damage. Ignoring the minor set back,
Mahito's cursed technique returns and he
prepares to end Todo with his next use
of Idle Transfiguration. Todo's necklace which
was slightly cut back when he cut his hand off,
suddenly falls and clatters opens, revealing a
picture of Yuji along with that Idol he loves,
that catches Mahito's eye and distracts him
for just a moment. This gives Todo enough
time to clap using Mahito's hand in order
to activate Boogie Woogie one more time!
Having slapped that hand, Todo switches
places with Yuji, who is already in the
middle of swinging a devastating right hook.
Watching the first approach, Mahito realizes his
predicament far too late, before he is struck
directly in the face by Yuji's Black Flash.
Nearby, Todo lays on the ground away from
the fight looking at his hand, grateful that
its only slightly burned from touching Mahito.
Extremely thankful for all his help in the battle,
Yuji looks back towards his big bro and silently
thanks him, but now he’s gonna take it from here.
Heavily injured, Mahito activates Soul
Multiplicity and creates another Polymorphic
Soul Isomer to hold off Yuji. The sorcerer
and the transfigured human trade parries and
punches in quick succession while Mahito hangs
back trying to regain his breath. Mahito admits
getting hit with Black Flash at this stage of the
fight is bad and commends Todo for being a pain
in the ass until the very end. The special grade
quickly disregards this because he believes he's
found the truest essence of his soul after
unleashing Black Flash for a second time.
In a matter of moments, Yuji uses a spinning
kick to defeat the Polymorphic Soul Isomer
before turning his attention back to Mahito.
Looking at the patchy curse, he notices Mahito
changing his shape along with a massive burst
of cursed energy being emitted by the process.
Activating Idle Transfiguration, the cursed
spirit sheds his human-like appearance and
evolves into his final form, the Instant
Spirit Body of Distorted Killing. Feeling
reborn, Mahito asks Yuji to celebrate the
occasion by wishing him a happy birthday.
Yuji can feel that this transfiguration
is unlike any other and wonders what
improvements it brings to his
opponent. Happy with himself,
Mahito explains that because he's learned
black flash he finally understands his true,
unbridled soul. Screwing up his face in disgust.
Yuji jokes that he didn't take Mahito as one
for a journey of self-discovery. Jokingly
agreeing with him, the curse also believes
that he's just getting started, and only once
he's killed Yuji can he truly feel born anew.
Using the improved strength granted by Instant
Spirit Body of Distorted Killing, Mahito whips
his hand and creates a giant shockwave to try
and take the sorcerer out. Yuji's reflexes are
fast enough for him to roll under the whip like
appendage and dive straight into a head kick.
Mahito, who like bruh are those glasses or is he
blind now and on the toth level auditory spec,
avoids the head kick and wraps the tendrils
from his head around Yuji's foot. Instantly
the curse rapidly retracting the tendrils wounding
the students foot. The cursed spirit follows up by
whipping his tail at the sorcerer, but Yuji
manages to block the strike with his knee.
Getting in close to each other
blocks Mahito throws a left hook,
still Yuji parries the attack and delivers a
swift hit to the body while Mahito's hand is
deflected. Making things even more difficult for
our boy, it turns out that Mahito's transformed
state provides skin so tough it even surpasses
Choso's hardened blood and nullifies his attack.
With one arm blocked, Mahito uses his free arm to
attacks with the tendril blades on the back of his
elbow. This slash cuts open the side of Yuji's
blocking arm and allows Mahito to capitalizes
while his adversary is on the backfoot. Darting
in, Mahito follows up with a flurry of rapid
blows, each with an increasing speed and ferocity.
Yuji is initially able to deflect everything,
proving just how naturally gifted he is, but
he soon finds that his counterattacks aren't
reaching him at all. This show of strength
forces the sorcerer to recognize that Mahito
has evolved into a completely different
being than before his transformation.
Breaking through the faltering guard, Mahito
grabs Yuji's face and slams him into the street,
destroying the ground from the impact and
collapsing them back into the train tunnels
of Shibuya. The falling rubble then smashes the
piping, causing the crater to slowly begin filling
with water. Standing in a pool of water, Yuji
knows the only way he can achieve victory is by
landing a Black Flash. No more specifically,
he needs to lay him out with a black flash,
imbued with his maximum cursed energy.
Remembering the time he was told that
there isn't a single sorcerer who can use
it at will, Yuji slightly loses his footing
due to general exhaustion and the ground
beneath his feet giving way to the water.
Mahito attempts to take advantage of Yuji's small
lapse by rushing in. However, the cursed spirit
immediately stops. The tendrils on the back of his
elbows partially disintegrate and the patch face
goon even begins coughing up blood. Cracking up at
how tired he’s become, Mahito knows that getting
hit by Black Flash so soon after activating
Domain Expansion seriously injured him. Yuji
on the otherhand, bangs on his leg in order to
wake it back up and regain his balance. Amused
with their final standoff, Mahito states that
both of them still have plenty left in the tank.
Mahito makes the first move, creating
a giant splash in the water from his
incredibly fast movements. Yuji
immediately clenches his fist
in his palm and channels all of his cursed
energy into it. Bursting through the water,
Mahito attempts to attack Yuji from behind
but our boy ducks under the strike in time,
before easily parrying the curses follow up
strike. Facing each other and with nowhere to run,
Yuji and Mahito prepare to let loose
with their own powered up strikes.
Inside of Jujutsu kaisen, not a
single sorcerer is able to use black
flash at will. In this moment of the battle
though, Yuji has performed so well with it,
that he fools you, making you
think, that thats what he’s doing!
Mahito is fully aware Yuji will try and end
the fight using Black Flash. He knows going
in recklessly will end in his demise and so in
preparation, has set in motion a countermeasure.
In the midst of their exchange of punches.
Mahito partially deactivates the Instant
Spirit Body of Distorted Killing to the
left side of his body catching Yuji by
surprise. He plans on transfiguring his body
to avoid the attack while also reinforcing the
deactivated area with cursed energy. With Yuji's
cursed energy completely focused in his fists,
Mahito believes his neck is wide
open and thats how he’ll end it!
As suspected, Yuji lands his punch on the
deactivated area of Mahito's body. Believing
he's won, Mahito swings at Yuji's neck with his
elbow blade. However, a sudden second impact
completely throws off the trajectory of Mahito's
slash, dumbfounding the silly curse.. So you see,
back in the past Divergent Fist was born out of
Yuji’s bad habits and overtime corrected them,
losing the technique in the process. But earlier
on in Shibuya and ever since his fight with Choso,
Yuji has been able to control Divergent Fist
and has used it to disrupt Mahito's plan.
Having ducked underneath Mahito's
previous attack, Yuji prepares his own,
while Mahito nervously tries to slash back with
his elbow. Suddenly a familiar voice tells the
cursed spirit to listen closely, as there
is no way he doesn't know this fact already.
Looking like HE HIMSELF, HIMOTHY, Todo Stands
above the crater and still determined to help
his best friend. He tells the cursed spirit
that an arm is merely a decoration... and,
while swinging his limbs together one last time
states that, the act of applause is
the acclimation of the soul itself.
Due to Todo's charisma and the threat of
Boogie Woogie activating, Mahito immediately
turns around to anticipate switching places.
He slashes behind him but hits nothing but air,
completely fooled by the utter genius of
a big brother. Looking down with a smile,
Todo apologizes for lying and claims that his
Boogie Woogie cursed technique has already died.
Set up with a clean shot from his bro, Yuji
lands a devastating direct maximum cursed
energy black flash hit to the curses
rib cage, sending him shooting off,
smashing into the top of the crater,
before finally stopping back above ground.
Stumbling around like a complete bafoon and back
inside of his normal form now. Mahito attempts to
vomit up more transfigured humans in an attempt
to fight back, but he's completely run out.
Strolling upto the curse, Yuji admits that
Mahito was right after all. He’s Him. He
wanted to reject Mahito and convince himself the
curse was wrong. But that doesn't matter now,
he’s gonna merc his ass. Even if he comes back
as another curse, he’ll kill him. Change ya name,
face or form and he’ll still be there to kill him.
He no longer needs to find some form of meaning or
reasoning from exorcising curses. Maybe a hundred
years or so later after his own death, the meaning
for these actions might become apparent. In the
grand scheme of things.. He’s probably noting
more than a cog, but that no longer matters to
him. For as long as he lives, this is his role.
Seeing Yuji's determination to
fulfill his role as a sorcerer,
Mahito flees terrorfied for the approaching doom.
Like a wolf running down a hare in the snow,
Yuji looks down apon his prey and stalks him
with an intent not yet seen. Suddenly an even
greater wolf arrives when Kendrippyaku appears
before Mahito, asking if he'd like to be saved.